even if you don't understand story
structure
you feel it this is sort of the
foundation of how you create that
emotional experience for the audience or
for the readers your protagonist goes
through a series of experiences that
lead to a transformation everything in
the story must keep changing point of no
return is the one moment that's external
to the character which is a very
specific thing that happens once in the
screenplay the clock isn't ticking quite
as fast yet think of it as
four 15 minute scripts that each one
builds on the last that's one of the
things that confuses people when they're
trying to learn about the 15 beats
you're writing 120 page script or you
know it's 10 pages of sequence if you
write if you're more like 100 page
script it's eight or nine pages of
sequence it's not deciding what you will
write it's providing a form
and a template with which the writer
pours their story into there's not
enough scenes here there's not enough
that's happening for this to fill two
hours i feel like i've heard about that
before what is this crazy thing called
the hero's journey we're all talking
about the same stuff it's really just
here's your pie you're gonna slice it
into eighths or sixteenths or whatever
every writer has a different
process and a way of thinking about
stories so i think it's really good to
expose yourself as a writer to all the
different models and see okay which one
helps me and that's what a carpenter
would do if he wanted to make a table he
would take a table apart
and see how it was put together that's
what a mechanic would do if he wanted to
build an engine creative people might
want to resist oh no you're going to you
know
make it too rigid
actually it's freeing it's freeing if
you know where you're going you can go
there very well
if you're lost you have a hard time
making anything work out
i would look at screenplay structure as
how you tell a story
and depending upon the kind of
screenplay you're writing the structure
is different
in general we've all learned about three
act structure in some way shape or form
um that three act structure can then be
broken down into just two acts if you're
writing a half hour multi-camera comedy
it can be spread out into four or five
or six acts if you're doing a one hour
drama but your half hour single camera
and your features are usually told in
three acts and if you wanna break it
down and make it as simple as possible
your first act is your setup
it's giving me all the information i
need to know of why i am here
your second act is the journey to reach
the goal
and then your third act is
what happened now that i reached the
goal right so it's your resolution so
you have your setup your journey and
your resolution and so if you can
understand that anytime we hear a story
bedtime story
dr seuss
what happened last weekend
we're all listening for the setup
the journey to success or failure and
then what happened after that so to me
that's like the simplest way of talking
about what structure is for a screenplay
one of my favorite uh instructors that i
worked with his name is ron mita
he taught a class
over in valencia
and he wrote
swat and then i think he sold some stuff
he developed robots for blue sky or
something
really good guy very practical um
great writer very cool guy he's amazing
for pitching as well
and he had this he was the one that
introduced me to this idea of just 24
plot points
and um
and he said just you know literally just
write down 24 just 24 numbers and just
put pp plot point plot point and then
break it down into you know the first
act
uh and then you know most people say
first second and third
but everybody divides it at the midpoint
plot point six is end of act one plot
point twelve is a midpoint plot point
eighteen is your low point and then plot
point i think it was
21 is your climax and then after that's
falling action
very simple and it's like we would we
would literally just sit there and plot
out a story in an hour
and it's it's super pragmatic
so from there
um it really came down to
trying to understand all right if we
keep dividing everything in midpoint
like pilar for example she'll use uh act
a 2a and 2b
and it kept on begging this question
what is an act the way i look at an act
is essentially defined by strategies
so a character
the the first act is a character
has a specific strategy which is their
normal daily life this is the value
systems that they that have gotten them
to this point in life
so when the impetus comes in and throws
their life out of balance they find
suddenly that they have to they start to
negotiate it and try and be like well i
don't want to change my life i don't
want to do anything but the second they
cross that threshold
and begin to
shift into a new strategy
then they've crossed into a new act
so what i've found every single time is
that um act two for example
um you usually have a character that's
you know trying something new like
tootsie um
how did you know i watched that as a kid
oh god it's so great public is brilliant
um
so
uh
you have michael dorsey who's dressed as
dorothy michaels and he's having success
and everything he's doing is bringing
more and more success and it looks like
hey this new strategy is working before
that his strategy was i'm going to be a
difficult actor
until no one will work with him so he
hits his breaking point all right i'm
going to dress as a woman and commit
completely to the role and
and he sees nothing but success until
you hit the midpoint
when
everything that he's doing
feels like it's paying off but
ultimately betrays his authenticity
so
it's at the midpoint where
basically you feel like you're getting
everything you want and this can com is
completely subjected to the needs of the
story this is just generally how the um
how the structure tends to go but when
you hit the midpoint often you're you
learn that you are as far away from your
original objective as you could be
thinking that you're just about to
achieve it generally speaking
and that realization whatever that is
the introduction of a new conflict or
something like that
creates a kind of
a shift in strategy and usually that
strategy is very like frantic and coping
and so all the value systems that had
informed that earlier strategy of hey
everything's gonna work you hit the
midpoint and it's failing and you just
come tumbling down the mountain until
you get down to the low point because
all
the the first two acts are all about
setup
and then the second two are all about
payoff so that sec that that third what
i define as an act what is 2b but i just
call it act 3. it's easier that way
is really just a strategy of collapsing
down the hill until you get to the low
point
so all of those choices are paying off
but for the bad
gil calls me up and goes i just
discovered this really cool book called
the hero within it's got these six
archetypes and i was looking at some of
the movies that i really like and i
noticed that the main character
moves
through four of the six archetypes like
clockwork
i was like really
so you're saying yeah it's like act one
the main character is an orphan of some
kind either a figurative orphan or a
literal often orphan so the main
character is an orphan of some kind in
act one act two
they become a wanderer
then we'll we'll tie it back to the
central question at some point but act
two they become a wanderer act three in
my four act structure they become a
warrior and act four they become a
martyr
it's like wow it's really interesting it
can't possibly be true but it's really
interesting and i started looking at
movies and stories and going oh my god
it is true like every well-constructed
story the main character goes through
these four archetypes
like clockwork um you know and it's it
just became like this it almost became
like the
it's like one of the
defining cornerstones
of
you know of um
of my whole understanding of story was
that like so many things kind of like
fell into place
as a result of understanding those four
archetypes
even to the point where
like one of the earliest
kind of aha moments i had was
talking to an exec at disney um
who i pitched some story i don't
remember what it was anymore i pitched
him a story and he went yeah that was
okay but your story you know didn't
answer the
four
central questions
i was like
okay
what what might those four central
questions be
and it's like who's your main character
you know what are they trying to
accomplish who's trying to stop them and
what happens if they fail
right so
so suddenly you went
you know
understanding the archetypes
suddenly start
started to shed some light on
the the central question that not
central questions the uh you know the
four questions
of of the film like who's your main
character it's on the orphan what's he
trying to accomplish that's wanderer
right you know who's trying to stop them
right that's warrior because somebody's
trying to stop you you're going to stop
them back that's warrior and what
happens if they fail that's martyr so
it's like suddenly like everything
started folding in on itself
you know that these archetypes started
now relaying relating to you know the
four main questions of uh you know of
your story which just started relating
into the four acts of the
of the structure
that i had you can now start saying oh
well act one
is who's your main character
and orphan now act two right and it's
just everything just started like
like lining up really really neatly as a
result of that
beginning middle obstacle climax that's
what that stands for um well i i found
this out years ago analyzing all movies
that it was equally emc square moment
for me there are four crescendos in a
movie where the heroes asked to change
and asked to learn the theme of the
movie and ask to learn how to heal
all the things i talk about the big
things i talk about healing learning a
theme
stopping bleeding all that there's four
times in a movie story
inevitably that that happens at a
crescendo it's at 30 pages in 60 pages
in 90 pages in and about 108 pages in
those i call the beginning middle
obstacle climax the bmoc right now
that's a structure that is in every
great movie practically you've ever seen
it's not in a goddard movie okay if
you're writing a french wave movie i'm
sorry i won't be able to help you that's
just a french guy peeing in an alley for
two hours and that's great right i love
those movies but but in a in a hollywood
film
um that structure is
invariably in the story and if it's not
there's usually something missing it'll
be superseded someday but that's what's
operating now now that bmoc operates in
everything um
uh ev every movie uh dunkirk uh um in
deadpool
um everything but now in deadpool let's
just take an example in deadpool which
is a great movie
again i'm big on wounds right what's our
wound in the deadpool the guy well he's
wounded because he's ugly he becomes
extremely disfigured by a chemical bath
right
and because of his wound i'm ugly
uh he can't face his girl he doesn't
feel lovable so the big crescendos the
bmoc points in that movie are is he
gonna have the the balls or or the
courage to believe that his his girl
will love him even though he's ugly okay
so what he's got to learn in there to
heal his wound is i'm lovable his wound
is i'm not lovable right
and and that's a wound we can all
identify with what a lot of us think
we're not lovable so he's his journey in
deadpool the crescendos of the movie are
are you going to realize you're lovable
well the answer for for him is
yes no no no yes yes no no yes because
after he gets uh chemically uh doused he
he's too ugly and it takes him most of
the movie to get to where he can take
his mask off that's the climax right
that's the final one takes the mask off
now i use deadpool i could use a more
highfalutin movie but i want people to
understand these these this pattern of
the bmoc works in every movie now you
can say wow that's great here that's a
tool ah so what
the tool will help you write your movie
you got to figure out what your theme is
you got to figure out what your
character's wound is and you have to
figure out how they're going to be
healing it that's it those are the three
things so this tool
works
in
drama and in comedy and tv as well
because why
because what we want to see in a story
is a hero
learning to heal
and even if he doesn't heal completely
because he doesn't in tv he's still
going to go on a journey towards healing
a little bit
the critical difference between film and
television is in tv the hero doesn't
heal but he heals a little bit and then
at the end he gets ripped open again so
every week he's going to heal a little
bit and then get ripped open again every
week 150 times but the bmoc works at the
exact same places in the television hour
than it does in a movie
there's just an extra m
because there's an extra act
so let's take a four act television
structure the bmoc it's bmmoc
the oc the obstacle point
is the point when it looks like the year
is going to lose and in a movie this is
right at the 90 page point let's take a
movie everybody knows star wars uh luke
gets to the planet the last rebel planet
uh darth has followed him there with a
homing beacon
he's got a death star he's gonna blow up
the whole damn thing there's nothing
luke can do about it there's just a
little few starfighters and he's got a
death star that's it the movie's over
and then of course what happens r2d2
says hey i stole the plans of the death
star there's a little hole you can fill
a missile in if you really get close and
luke you can the only one get that
missile in that hole if you use the
force not your computer and so the
obstacle point is all is lost and the
climaxes luke learns the theme of the
story
luke will you use the force to rescue
the princess and save the republic he
puts his computer away all the other
starfighters used it they couldn't get
the missile in he puts his computer away
he's learned he hears oh we want to say
luke
use the force not the computer and he
puts the missile in the whole climax so
the obstacle point is always lost and
the climax is luke you did it in
breaking bad the obstacle point is he's
making meth in the desert jesse comes
back out with the crazy eight and the
other uh criminal they're gonna kill
them both walt's in his underwear he has
no defense he's gonna get shot and
killed but then he says i'll teach you
i'll teach you how to cook i'll teach
you how to cook my recipe
and the guy goes
really
yes and they go in the rv
and walter throws poison into the thing
whoosh and the climax is he kills them
both and becomes the mass murder he's
gonna be for the next 150 episodes so
that's the climax so the o and the c
point and i'm not explaining this well
i'm sorry but it's in my lecture online
it's a complex little tool but it works
so great it's like a little engine that
works any television structure you want
just like it did in film
let me preface it by saying this is what
it's sort of built on i mean my
underlying philosophy of all
storytelling whether you're a novelist
or screenwriter movie maker tv writer
whatever it might be is that your
primary goal as a storyteller must be to
elicit emotion you must create an
emotional experience for the audience if
it's a movie or a play or for the reader
if you're a screenwriter and you have to
get get it read so you can get the movie
made or if you're a novelist or whatever
so your primary goal has to be to create
emotion and this is a way to
accomplish that goal these are the this
is sort of the foundation of how you
create that emotional experience for the
audience or for the reader
and so
these six stages are the six stages
you're going to take your hero through
and also the audience through as we go
from the beginning of the story to the
end
so the first of the six stages what
constitutes the first ten percent of the
story is what i call the setup that's
simply where we introduce the hero you
create an emotional connection to that
character you show her living her
everyday life
then there's a turning point the
opportunity something new happens that
takes us into the second stage that's
the next 15
of the movie
or the script uh by the way the
percentage is if novelists are watching
this are a little more fluid you don't
have to stick quite as closely but in
scripts there are one or two pages on
either side of these percentages pretty
pretty consistently so the second stage
the second 15 of the movie is what i
call a new situation your hero has now
been presented with some event that
takes them somewhere new it might be
geographically new or just some new
circumstance where they have to figure
out what's going on
then something happens at the one
quarter mark at the end of act one
that is going to move the character
towards a specific
visible goal they are going to then
declare and begin pursuing
a specific finish line that they want to
reach by the end of the story my term
for that is the outer motivation for the
character because it's outwardly visible
and it's their desire so it might be to
stop a serial killer it might be to win
the love of the
love interest in the movie whatever now
they begin pursuing that so they go into
act two and the first half of act two is
stage three
that's progress they formulate a plan
and the plan seems to work and the
obstacles start getting bigger and
bigger until finally at the midpoint of
that story
they're going to make a bigger
commitment to the goal up to that point
they sort of have one foot in one foot
out now they're going to reach what i
call the point of no return
something's going to happen that demands
of them that they sort of put both feet
in so they're going to devote everything
they can now to achieving the goal they
can't back up they burn their bridges
behind them so to speak so that moves
them into stage four which is
complications and higher stakes because
the further into the story the character
goes
the more is at stake because it the goal
becomes more and more important to them
but also the harder it is to achieve the
goal the outside world is going to start
closing in the bad guy's going to
discover that the hero is after him or
whatever it might be so it gets tougher
and tougher and tougher until at the
three-quarter mark right at the end of
act two the hero is going to suffer or
encounter a major setback something's
going to happen that destroys seemingly
any hope of achieving the goal
the plan is out the window the worst
possible thing that could happen happens
and so in response to that the hero will
do two things first the hero is going to
retreat and try and go back to the life
they were living at the beginning and
give up on the goal but that doesn't
work they're not satisfied they're not
fulfilled or they just can't give up
because somebody's life is at stake or
whatever so then they make one last all
or nothing do or die final push and
that's the stage five which is the final
push it's putting everything on the line
giving every ounce of courage and energy
they have until they reach the final
turning point the fifth turning point
and that's the climax that's where
everything gets resolved that's where
the hero faces the villain for the last
time or the hero wins the love of the
love interest and and they decide
they're going to live happily ever after
or whatever that climax might be
and then the sixth stage is what i call
the aftermath because we need to see the
new life that this hero that this
character is going to live having
completed this journey
and that's pretty much it it's it's like
a before and after picture starting out
in an everyday life going through this
journey to accomplish this goal and then
in the end seeing how their life has
been transformed because they took this
journey
i think the parts that that cause people
that make people the most curious
have to do with our analysis of a movie
of the week and that when we first wrote
the book there were a lot of movies of
the week
in which we talked about the seven act
structure of a television show
and the 7x structure you know there is a
3x structure to stories all stories have
a three-act structure
but in the renaissance for example
stories had five acts
and that's because they divided the
horrible act 2 that everyone hates i
call it the serengeti plane
because it's you know it's the hardest
part of the writing
they divide it into three acts and now
there's a five act story and it's easier
to write because each act has a
beginning middle and end and each act
can be subdivided into twists and turns
and scenes so
television goals goes even further and
makes it seven acts and that's because
of commercials that have to come after
each act etc so people were
curious to see that but when they saw
that that the executives at the studios
actually had a chart
some of them actually took the chart
into a pitch meeting and wrote down
jotted down
what you know in the chart
what the writer what the pitch was
saying about what happens in each act
and so on so here's the filled out one
i'm based on a movie that we produce
and it shows
one-liners of the scenes that occur in
each act and i think people
realize that this was
they didn't realize how mechanical it
was and honestly when i hear that which
i do often from writers when i'm in the
old days at least when i was teaching
university extensions all over the
country
i realized that they didn't have the
mentality to be writers so let me give
you a great example a woman named millie
meyer god rest her soul wonderful
wonderful lady he was a client for years
came up to me at a riverside uc
riverside workshop after and she goes i
didn't want to say anything in front of
the class because i didn't want people
to make fun of me but
i took my favorite book the grapes of
wrath
and i outlined it
and is that stupid and i said no you're
the only craftsman in the class
i mean that's what a carpenter would do
if he wanted to make a table he would
take a table apart
and see how it was put together that's
what a mechanic would do if he wanted to
build an engine he'd take an engine
apart so that's exactly what you do
and
when i when they see this kind of
breakdown
they understand
you know exactly
how the mechanics of it work and
honestly until you get to that point
you're really not ready to be a
professional writer because if you
thought that writing was a magic you
know magic trick
that you have to pull off every time or
a miracle which i guess most writers
probably would think miracle rather than
magic trick
then it's impossible
right but it's not possible i mean it's
not impossible it's possible to be a
writer people have been writers for
centuries they've been storytellers and
and storytellers tell stories in parts
and they know what the parts are
and they do them in a way that makes
sense
and so the sooner you get down to the
mechanics of how it works the better and
that's what we try to do in our books is
to show people the mechanics i'm looking
through for another there's another page
in here where we show
what we call an intensity chart
where
you
kind of type one liners of your whole
story on it on a single piece of paper
one-liners of all the important scenes
in the story then you go
between the lines and let's say you put
hyphens
two hyphens for a
non-dramatic scene or a scene with
relatively little drama and like five
hyphens for a scene with much more drama
and ten hyphens with maximum
drama right so now you've got
a page that has all these hyphens on it
underneath the sentences right
then you draw a line across the hyphens
uh connecting the hyphens and then you
turn it on its side
you turn the piece of paper on its side
and what you've got is something that
looks like a roller coaster
and it because it shows you the ups and
downs in your stories
based on the drama the intensity of the
drama in your stories and
that is a great diagnostic tool because
if you see that there's a whole slope
that in which the thing keeps going down
down down and doesn't go up for a while
or it levels off then you know you need
to work on that part of your story so
that's what i call the mechanical
approach you know what i mean by
mechanics like when you when you want to
outline a screenplay or a book
you just use three three by five cards
and you put on those three by five cards
the obligatory scenes in the book
and
you won't fill up a whole card because
it'll just be a couple of words on each
card
and
what you understand when you start doing
that is that
creation of a literary work
is what aristotle called an imitation of
reality it's not reality you're not re
you know building
the cider house and and
the world around the cider house you're
faking it you're making the reader
believe it's there
and you do that mechanically by
like i would if i were making the movie
i build a house
front
that looks like this outer cider house
right but it wouldn't have a back
because i'm only going to shoot the
front of it
so that's what you're doing when you're
writing you're you're just doing what's
necessary to create the illusion that
you're trying to create and the audience
believes that the illusion is real
because it wants to believe that and
you've given them enough evidence to
make them believe it so you know when
you're watching one of the old movies
when they were just nobody was dealing
with production value the way we do now
you know it just takes a little bit to
make you believe in the story even if
the acting is bad
right even if the set is laughable but
you still are in the story if the story
is good you know if if the characters
are good and the dialogue is good
and that's
one of the things that we try to instill
in writers is learn the mechanics of it
because it's easier than
then you make it you're not having to
recreate a whole world you're you need
to do the right
strokes
to make the painting look like a person
and uh
that's
what we try to do in you know the
treatment book
this this shows you what you know this
is what you're doing as you do it you
you're writing little search sentences
and you're putting hyphens and then
you're drawing a line connecting them
all but then when you put it on the side
you can see the shape of your story
and you can see where it needs some
attention you know where that you know
there's all these peaks here but no real
valleys so it would be much more
dramatic if you dropped
some of the intensity or you added less
intense scenes in here so that the rises
would be greater etc and you know it
could be that everything is just fine
when you do this and it looks really
perfect but most the time you'll
discover that it's not a roller coaster
ride which is what you want you know
your reader to go on you want them to
to be screaming all the time basically
and then toward the end you see the
highest peak and then it levels down
yeah it levels down although
you know in today's storytelling world
maybe this is not the right way to end
the story
you know it might be better to end on a
higher peak
i break it down into seven steps based
similar to to blake's system so i it's a
simple way to say it is i tell the story
i get them to tell the story or do my
own work in one sentence and then five
sentences and then 15 sentences which is
like blake's 15 beats and then 40
sentences which is basically a sentence
for each
scene in the movie more or less
those are the first four steps and then
the other three are screenplay draft
steps so you have get it down get it
good and get it great
um and and it's and it's a problem all
those those things are they're steps but
they're really
almost like um
there's seven different ways the
audience is craving answers about your
story and most writers that aren't like
fully firing on all pistons aren't
answering those questions as deeply as
they could so i'm good at doing that in
my work at least enough and then i get
feedback and i figure out how to do it
even better and when i work with other
people i just make sure that they're
fully answering those questions and then
when they get to the screenplay writing
part um
get it down as just as quickly as you
can
you're almost like formatting it i
usually tell like a write a treatment in
that fourth stage after i do like the 40
um sort of sentences for each scene i'll
kind of write that into a treatment five
pages 15 pages and that was copy and
paste that into the screenplay format
and then i'm just almost reformatting it
cliche this cliche that doesn't matter
bomb but just kind of scaffolding
that's that that that um
step um five and then step six is get it
good it's not great it's just kind of
okay you got a mess of cliches and
whatever but you kind of organize it a
little bit just kind of easy breezy
momentum flow
and then after a few drafts of that
you're like okay this is working you're
getting good feedback
again we're in the reaction game so it's
not enough if you want to be
professional
that um that i dislike it's like i have
to like it and then it's coming across
other people and they're saying it's
great um and then when you're getting
that good then you get into that fine
tuning safe get it get it great so it's
gonna get it down get it good get it
great and what i see most mistakes they
make so this is that seven step process
inspired by blake's people will get a
loose idea right here like step one and
it'll jump to like step seven and it's a
fiasco
and even if they finish the script um
you can see it the scripts is a mess
and sometimes
you know if they tell me what their
script idea is in one sentence
um
it'll it'll also be a mess and i can
just i can just by seeing the one
sentence i know the same problems they
have in a 100 page script starting with
you know the log line and premises is
huge and then 15 beats is really helpful
but in between those two there's i i do
five sentences so act one act two a or
what blake calls fun and games your
midpoint turn
and then act two b and then act three
so it's more or less the three act
structure but it's broken out into these
pieces i mean this is a turning point
but like it's so important to kind of
call it out and so sometimes when i'm
even coming up with a movie idea for the
in the very beginning i'll kind of have
a couple pieces of the concept and i'll
actually maybe sketch it out the five
the five sentences but it's all easy
it's kind of like well oh i know it's
going to end and i'm not quite sure
about this part of that part so i just
fill in what i know and go to the other
parts and just kind of play with it and
then it just comes together
if it's a good idea and if it's easy
it'll come together and if it's not
coming together at least right now i
just put it aside do something else that
is easy blake goes from concept to 15 uh
what he calls beats
but they're not even really beats it's
um
it's he's what he'll have is in his 15
beats are there's some turning points
and there's sequences
and then he's got opening image closing
images which is a great bookending
device and then he calls out your b
story which is your second most
significant thread and then he um he
talks about the theme
how it should be stated early on and
overtly
um
and and that's it so there's a few
things that are um
but it's kind of a weird word so i i
kind of think of his sort of 15 story
but they're all pertinent it's like i
for sure am writing a better screenplay
when i have good answers for each of
those 15 things whatever you want to
call them one of the things i added to
my process that he doesn't really talk
about is it's my step four process right
it'll um and most movies will have about
40 scenes you know plus or minus 5 or 10
or whatever so um i want to get a sense
of i'll expand those 15 beats to like
the 40 scenes and if it's 35 i don't
care it's fine i just note oh i'm a
little bit short because here's the
thing the thing with structure that
throws up off a lot of people is
especially people that aren't
comfortable with it yet they're like i
don't want to follow those rules it's
confining me
and they use that exact tone of voice
so but
what's most instructive to me and how i
also work with you know my mentees or
students or whatever i um
it's the expectations of the audience
the audience is absolutely
craving
beginning middle and end they're craving
your your break into act two to happen
someplace around you know the late 20s
you know 25 minutes 20 blake says 27
minutes so it doesn't have to be on that
page but um but if i write it and it's
five pages after that or ten pages i'm
aware of that and it's the opportunity
to go i know the audience is expecting
this around 27
do i have enough legit have i earned
their trust to go longer um am i so it's
totally fine to sort of go against their
expectations um but i want to do it
mindfully um or it's an opportunity to
go huh
i'm you know my i'm breaking into two at
you know page 35
is there something i can oh you know
what i totally can cut this whole scene
or trim this down and then i get it
closer so it's an opportunity to very
definitively look at what the audience
is expecting in a very concrete way and
go do i want to play two audience
expectations here or go against it so
specifically with the 40
um you know 40 sentences for the scenes
you know again plus or minus 5 or ten or
whatever um
i'll do that and then i i um so i so i
have the sort of bone structure of how i
can go and i often put them on index
cards and a board in my my home office
and um
and uh and then i'd like to go from
there before i go to the script to
actually write a treatment as well for
two reasons one is
the
those 40 cards are really good for sort
of structural choices and sort of thread
flow and that sort of thing
but they don't get the feeling really of
the story so that's why i go to a
treatment and then the second reason is
you know nobody's going to look at my 40
beats and really get what i'm doing so
if i want feedback and i get a lot of
feedback in the treatment stage
i read the treatment and then i can you
know five pages 10 pages whatever it
takes the screenplay that i'm working on
now i actually did three drafts of the
treatment got really good feedback
between everyone then realized that i
wanted to change the protagonist from
one character to the other
and then did three more drafts of the
treatment and then felt it was good and
then i'm into the screenplay so by the
time i get to the screenplay my first
draft
you know it's not really a first draft
because i've spent so much time
designing the story doing the treatment
it's
it's
by probably typical you know
fifth draft or tenth draft for other
people
so i do have a few moments in time and
by moments in time i'm talking about the
first scene and the last scene so we're
going to identify in the first scene
what a character
wants
uh and then we're going to have a next
moment that identify is what i call the
point of no return
this is the big event that's going to
push us into the main part of the story
it's the event that makes this movie
this movie
um
everything else on here is internal to
the character the point of no return is
the one moment that's external to the
character it's the one thing that has to
happen to them
um so
uh so we're talking about groundhog day
right so the the point of no return is
when he wakes up and discovers it's the
same day again right and it should feel
like it's this moment makes this movie
this movie without that scene you
wouldn't have the movie groundhog day
right it's absolutely essential so it's
an important like moment like that
that's going to drive the rest of the
story it's also external you notice it
wasn't the point of no return is never
somebody decides to do something
there's an element of fate that is
involved when we're looking at the point
of no return so of all the elements it's
the one thing that's external that had
to happen to him he could have not had
that happen it woken up and it was
february 3rd and then this movie
wouldn't be this movie but for whatever
reason he woke up and it was february
2nd all over again that's outside of his
control
um if we're going to look at the movie
tootsie sometimes people say oh the
point of no return is when he goes to
audition for the part
that's a choice
right so the point of no return needs to
be external to the character so i would
not identify it as he goes to audition
um what and
what you want to identify is the moment
outside of his control so the part where
everything really changes is when
so he could have blown that audition and
he almost blows that audition he comes
very close to blowing it but the female
producer likes him right and at one
point she says i like him i like her
we're gonna hire and she leans over and
says you've got the part i'm sending the
contract to your agent
that's the point of no return that
because that moment's outside of his
control right that had nothing to do
with his choice he could have blown that
audition he almost did blow that
audition but that's the moment boom now
we're in the movie known as tootsie
one another thing i like to think of a
great example of this is the differences
but going from act one and act two is
the wizard of oz
wizard of oz act one it's a black and
white
point of no return is she thinks that a
tornado has lifted her house up and
dumped her in the land of oz and boom
we're in technicolor
we want that feeling when we enter iraq
too
we're in a whole new world
we ain't in kansas anymore right so it's
a whole new world that there's facing
it's one thing michael dorsey decides to
audition one day as a woman it's another
thing he's got to fool everybody 24 7
into thinking he's a woman that's the
main story or in groundhog day he's now
trapped in a cycle where every day is
groundhog day that's the main part of
the story
um so there are two kinds of stories i i
talk about in the book comedy and
tragedy
um and these are not these definitions
don't come from don't blame me if you
don't like them they're from aristotle
these are the original academic
definitions of comedy and tragedy so
when i say comedy i'm not talking about
a haha comedy i'm talking about an
aristotelian comedy
and so an aristotelian comedy according
to aristotle by definition is where we
have a protagonist who overcomes a flaw
so flaw is gonna be the next element i'm
gonna talk about uh and that they're
they're gonna go through change and then
eventually they're gonna have a happy
ending um structurally we also have
tragedies a tragedy is going to be the
opposite so we have the same setup we
have a character want something they get
it in a point of no return but instead
of going down down down and then coming
up and having a happy ending we're going
to go in the opposite direction they're
going to go up up up before they come
down and have their sad ending
um 95 percent of stories are going to be
comedies by the way
yeah at least 95 the next important
thing to talk about when i talk about
the point of no return um in the point
of no no return the character gets
something they want they also get
something they don't want
um and that's going to be what i call
the catch
so you get what you want but with the
catch so michael dorsey gets a part but
he's gonna have to dress up as a woman
um uh in groundhog day phil connors only
has to spend 24 hours in punxsutawney
that was his want but the catch is it's
actually going to be the same 24 hours
done over and over again so the catch is
attached so it's a problem we can't just
give our character what they want um
because that deflates conflict
so you're giving them something that
they want along with something they
don't want
and the catch is also could be said to
be the perfect test of their flaw
so the um flaw in you know phil connor's
flaw is that he's self-centric this is
the that the catch being that he's gonna
stuck spending the same same day over
and over again is the perfect test if
someone spla is that they're
self-centered
uh in a comedy it's going to end in the
happy ending but they're going to go
down down down down
before because you got to hit rock
bottom before you can make a change
um so keep in mind in your typical haha
comedy and your typical haha comedy is
an aristotelian comedy it's down down
down down
we're laughing
as bad things are happening to the
protagonists they are not laughing they
are not having a good time in act two of
a comedy so they're gonna go down down
down until they're gonna hit rock bottom
uh what i call their crisis the crisis
has two requirements uh one is it's
their absolute lowest place
and then it is the other requirement is
that the opposite of the want
um actually groundhog dick has a really
interesting one
in that he's actually finally spent
after being stuck there
he finally
tells the truth to rita the love
interest
about what's going on and they actually
have kind of a wonderful day together
but it ends in this very bittersweet
moment where they're falling asleep
and he's um
says and the terrible worst part is
tomorrow you're going to think i'm a
jerk again
and
what is wonderful about it is this
wonderful irony
and that's what we're setting up with
the crisis being the opposite this irony
he only wanted to spend 24 hours in
pakistani
now he wishes the day could last forever
because tomorrow she'll think he's a
jerk again so we're sending this
delicious irony there
um
then the next thing we're going to
identify in the nutshell is we're now
entering the act three the beginning of
act three is the climax of your movie
uh and the operative word that we're
gonna use though is the climatic choice
at the heart of a true climax your
protagonist is making a difficult
decision
so in groundhog day his choice
is to start
stop to stop fighting it to accept that
he's there and start trying to live
every day for the fullest and so he
becomes a really good person he starts
you know doing nice things and saving
the day and doing thinking of others
because what's the point in uh living
and trying to
have short-term
gratitude uh he's got to find a
different experiment with a different
way of living so he actually starts
becoming this town hero of this person
who's the known as this good guy because
he's got nothing better to do
and then finally break some free of the
the curse and in the final step the
final step is the very last uh
structural element time wise the very
last scene of the movie
um and now the character's gonna come
full circle so if his uh flaw was that
he was self-centered he's come full
circle towards opposite strength that he
now is um selfless
and right because he's been doing these
things for everybody in the town of
wakes up that final pakistan and he's
actually it's become february 3rd he's
free of the curse and he actually wants
to stay
um so those are the eight structural
elements and so like i said it's not
just moments in time this is not a beat
sheet method um they are what's
important is the glue it's the the
structure that holds these pieces apart
it's the connection between these parts
these are not isolated moments in time
we can see right on the piece of paper
what's working and what's not and if
it's not working
how to adjust it by seeing that it fits
you know what what do we need to change
um in order to meet the requirements in
order to tell a story effectively
it originates in hollywood history
by the accident of um of the one real
film 35 millimeter film that became
standardized by the first decade of the
20th century the first movies by that by
that time let's say that by 1910 there
are single real experiences there are 10
minutes long
and
for various reasons in the
teens hollywood split in two directions
from the single reel
film
to
what we call full-length features
multi-reel films hour and a half two
hours three hours
and in the other direction to the serial
which is a real or two
installments series
and um
the uh
reason you have the origin of sequences
is that
in the u.s
the distribution system was so
rigorously one real a week or two wheels
a week that when they started to
generate full-length feature films they
were still distributed
a couple of reels a week
so
if you look at
manuals of the time screenwriting
manuals there are about 60 titles that
came out in the 19 teens on how to write
a photo play because the market was
kind of wide open and people wanted to
write these things
you'll get instructions about
making sure that each reel has a climax
to it
so that the audience will be interested
in seeing the next reel and then they'll
see the next one after that so it was
almost like a
limited series a feature film
by the late teens you're seeing them all
the distribution system is changing and
you're seeing in theaters what we would
normally experience
uh as a full-length feature but
the the idea of
writing by the real survived
into the 20s and 30s and you can see the
uh see the evidence of it in the
way the continuity scripts are marked
they're often marked by sequence letter
sequence a b c d
and that is
where
what we call sequences come the
nomenclature comes from
what frank danielle discovered
in
teaching in the 80s
he
discussed the three act structure in
terms of setting up a situation
developing it and then paying it off
but he found that the students struggled
with the middle part of the script
because it's intimidating how do you
fill up 60 pages in the middle and uh
usually 30 pages to set it up 60 pages
in the middle and 30 pages in the third
act
so he revived this idea of sequences he
said well don't think of it in terms of
one you know act of 60 pages think of it
as
four 15 minute scripts that each one
builds on the last
and um
so thus the the sequence approach is
born you're not going to try to tackle a
whole 120 pages just figure out these 15
minutes the first one first 15 minutes
and then the next 15 minutes then that's
going to really do some kind of
major problem for a character so then
they're going to try to explore the next
for the next 15 minutes and
the the effect is actually very
liberating because you wind up not
worrying about how you're going to fill
up these pages but more about how you're
going to trim down because now you've
got all this material but it also
helps you
explore a premise really fully
you have a character let's just take a
classic dramatic instruction a character
wants something and there's obstacles
okay at the end of the first act they we
know what they want we know what the
obstacles are going to be well
what is the character going to
character doesn't know what the movie's
about
character just thinks oh this is this is
easy i can solve this
so they try something and that's in your
conceptualization of the story the
character tries the easiest thing that
they can try and then the filmmaker the
screenwriter comes up with an obstacle
why that doesn't work
and that's maybe 10 15 minutes all right
so now they got to try something else
what's that going to be and you can
develop it and each sequence
has its own integrity
ideally the the paradigm is that each
sequence is going to have three acts
also it's going to have some kind of
setup you don't have to do as much setup
because we know the characters but
you're going to have to introduce new
circumstances they're going to try to
get something and then it's going to end
with some kind of resolution usually
negative because it's positive maybe the
movie's over
but it uh leads to the next sequence and
the next one um and
so
you wind up with actually a kind of a
nested structure
because the
scenes dramatic scenes have the same 3x
that's why i tend to like three acts you
can
depends on how you define it but if you
understand it as
working with tension which tension is
just
putting something in the audience's mind
hope and fear
character wants something
are they going to get it or not that's
what i'm wondering about and if i care
about the character then i'm going to
stay tuned because i want to see the
answer to that so it's you don't need
more than three acts for that you just
need to set that up and then you need to
develop it and then you get the answer
so each act
the act set up the whole thing then each
sequence
has its own okay character wants
something and there's problems and then
each scene
has a character that wants something and
there's obstacles so
it's like
this iterative structure that keeps the
audience
involved because we're constantly
wondering about what
how it's going to come out for the
character and one thing that we also we
cover in the book on the science of
screenwriting is
this this process of connection to a
main character and what the theories are
about why we um
uh have that and it's certainly
important if you come into a if you're
in a park and you come up on a tennis
game and two people are really battling
each other
it may be interesting but it's not going
to be dramatic to you as you don't know
them but if if you do know one if you
love one of them and you know that they
just mortgaged their house and put
everything on this game and then you
know the other person is a hustler
then every oh my god you've got
something it's transformational but you
have to make that connection emotionally
and
so um so to get back about the sequence
structure you
have
uh mini versions of
the
three acts in sequences and then in the
scenes and that is the suspense the
tension that keeps us interested and we
also we have a chapter on the contrast
in the film and that plays also into
this uh
approach which is that
in order to
maintain audience attention the stimulus
has to be changed frequently otherwise
you you
zone out
you you you'll lose connection
uh you you'll think about other things
and you need to reset the audience's
brain periodically and filmmakers do it
you can see evidence of it and
changing light and dark loud and soft
fast and slow but you also see it in
tension and release
tension maintained for too long gets
tedious but if you release it and give
us a chance to reset then you can go on
and build it up again and again and
again until you reach
the
culmination of the picture and then
finally
you try to release it entirely and
then people get people to say yeah i
want to see that movie again i'm going
to tell my friends i want to see it
but she basically says there are 11
steps in a feature film the first step
is the character's overall want and why
so you establish through action what
they want and why they want it
and then the character logically goes
for it so they take action to try to get
that thing that they want
but the character is somehow denied
okay they they that's not gonna work
they can't they can't get it that way
um but the character gets a second
opportunity
to um achieve their overall want
but
there's danger around that second
opportunity like it's kind of a shady
way maybe it's not on the up and up but
there's some danger around it either
emotionally or physically okay
but they want it so badly at the end of
act one
they go for it they decide to go for it
again
these these forms are the same like
they're just different language around
the same turning points and stuff but at
the end of act one the character decides
to go for it and now we're in act two
right and so um
all goes well they're going for it look
they're getting what they want oh my god
but
something happens in the middle of the
script and one thing i would love to
share with your viewers is this idea of
the midpoint you know um sometimes the
midpoint people think of it as like
something happens out of the blue that
that
causes everything to fall apart or it's
like a false victory
and then they have to deal with its
false or whatever but i always think the
best midpoints are a moment where the
character just like everything's going
okay they're getting what they want
but then they get to that cave and it's
like they're in that cave and their fear
is around them and they make a decision
out of fear
that causes everything to fall apart for
them they go back to their old pattern
and that actively gives them
like they drive that midpoint and and
causes everything to fall apart which in
jules um
um
11 step structure is called all falls
apart
right so all falls apart looks like
they're going to fail um and then at the
end of act two there's a crisis where
they again have to make a decision or a
commitment um
do they go for a new strategy do they
give up
you know what do they do usually they
decide to try again
and that decision or that crisis
decision drives them into act three um
and then we have this climax where it's
the final attempt to get what they want
and again usually we have a
transformation right they do something
they never could have done back in act
one they get what they want and then the
last phase she calls truth the truth
comes out to make things right and this
is where um
that the character discovers something
new about her world
she has some new insight about herself
and that usually has the power to heal
whatever was broken back at the
beginning of the story
um and so what i love about this this
story model is that it's really goal
driven
you know it's like they want something
they decide to go for it they get
blocked they get a second opportunity
i'm afraid i want it so much i'm going
to go for it it's just it allows you to
really find that goal for your character
and let them pursue that in the story
what i'll do is i'll start with the
premise line i'll write out a premise
line sort of
basically for me like the foundation of
the script couple of sentences take take
you know from start to finish um and
then i'll
expand that into i know maybe two three
four pages there's a sort of write it in
sections so i'll divide it into into
three basically if it's a movie three
movie acts but you know more in quarters
so it's like the equivalent of quarter
quarter quarter quarter which takes me
through the four quarters or the three
acts of the of the um of the movie um so
it it it's i can keep it because one of
the things that happens when you start
writing it for me and when i start
writing out and that writing outline in
um
you know uh
prose form is that you know if you don't
if you don't for me if i don't kind of
stop writing at a certain point you know
you end up with let's say your outline
is for pay you're writing it just
outlined four pages the first two pages
may really only be the first quarter of
your script because you know you you
know you end up writing so much and then
then you have to really then ultimately
you end up with kind of uh you know
disproportionate disproportionate uh
acts so basically i'm just trying to to
write it
as tightly as i can and i'll write it
long and then i'll then i'll edit it but
in the end i want to end up with kind of
four relatively close uh descriptions of
each quarter okay so let's say that's
that ends up being three four pages
whatever then if it's on if it's an
assignment then i'll then i'll give it
to the executive or whatever i'll get
notes on it rework it and then if it's
not for me i'll do the same thing for
myself and then what i do is
i divide
the um and this was a you know really i
have to credit writer's boot camp for
this because they really this was kind
of the way they taught me how to do it
and how i always do it now and i taught
other people and i i think it's pretty i
mean it's one of those things that just
sort of like i i don't think it's an
uncommon way to do it but it kind of
boils it down to i think a really
effective way of doing it is that um
you divide i divide it up into 12
sequences three sequences in the first
act six in the second act and three in
the third act of equal weight so
basically you know if you're writing 120
page script or you know it's 10 pages of
sequence if you write if you're more
like 100 page script it's eight or nine
pages of sequence and i beat out the
list of scenes so i'll take i turn i
create a sequence sentence you know so
this is sequence one two and three so
out of that sequence sentence that i
write right out pull from the outline
the longer outline i then
write a list of the scenes that will
comprise that that that that sequence so
i'll put like the scenes in a row
and then i'll figure out how many pages
that scene will approximately be so that
i can add it up add up each sequence and
say at the end those six scenes will
equal eight and a half pages or
something and it's an estimate it may
sometimes i'm very off but it's an
estimate
and this is just my kind of organized
way of doing it you know and and how i
don't get lost in the process you know
and how i really kind of stay on track
this is just mine everybody has their
way of doing it
and so i do that so ultimately you end
up with basically 12
series of of single of scene lists so
and which should ultimately when you add
it all up should equal you know whatever
your page desired page count is 100 105
pages 120 pages an estimate um and then
i take that i put that onto my final
draft
that list onto my final draft and i
create a slug line over each one you
know interior living room night exterior
you know baseball field date whatever
and and so i have the line and then i
you know the the what the what the scene
is about and then i have the slug line
so basically what i end up with is a
whole written script
except without dialogue essentially um
and then you go in and just you know you
craft it and to me it's just it's a very
step-by-step process so it's like an
accordion you're constantly expanding
that accordion until you have the whole
script written so
it that that that that works for me
um but everybody does it differently
distilled it down to writing a premise
or a log line
for the
for the
the overall
um idea of what the story would be and
that that premise or log line has the um
uh is is elastic in itself meaning that
it it can evolve it can change over time
you can always return to it and augment
it in some way as you are going through
the writing process
and then for each of the 12 beats
of my screenplay
so basically when i say 12 beats is if a
screenplay is technically 120 pages
um there's a beat for every 10 pages all
right
and then you're thinking of the story
and we're talking the story now
as an ekg
all right
so um what i mean by an ekg and you can
also apply this to christopher vogler's
ideas on the uh the hero's journey as
well
um the ekg is like
you are you're lifting off with your
inciting incident
um the inciting incident um technically
should occur anywhere from like the five
page two
to like
well in the old days it was like five
page the fir to thirty page but like
it's it's really just five pages now you
really don't go farther than that
and then um
and then what you do is you um you
plateau off as you get towards the um
towards the middle of the ekg so that's
like
um page 60 and that means basically that
your characters or your protagonist is
um on his way to um
towards his journey and so that's beat
six
and then um on on beat nine um you are
um you are um you are coming all the way
down on your ekg
um you're spiking downward because they
are facing all their adversity and all
of their obstacles that they must
overcome that they may never they may
never recover from and then if they do
recover and they do succeed and they win
in the end
then that ekg comes all the way back up
at 12.
if they don't if they don't win then
that ekg comes all the way up at 11 and
then goes sharply down at 12.
so
that is um
that is basically um
that 12 point
beat
outline now with the 12 point beat
outline each one of those beats 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
um has its own premise so every 10 pages
or approximately 10 pages because you
don't have to adhere
here um
strictly
to 10 pages because you know maybe you
have a shorter script
um has its own log line so you go this
is you know when such and such happens
such and such occurs cause and effect
it's a cause and effect statement that
is something that is that has a whole
chapter
in um la la segres um the um
the the art of of dramatic writing is
the cause and effect statement that goes
all the way back that that can apply all
the way back to the greeks
and he takes it there
so
so um you you do that um for each one of
those beats
um and then from each one of those um
log lines you use those as a basis to
to work on to script those 10 pages or
roughly those 10 pages and then if you
adhere to that
you'll you'll probably get yourself a um
a first draft
um it may not be much of a first draft
but it'll be something that you can you
can rewrite and that you can work on
a story map is a structural template
that's followed by most commercial films
and it breaks a story a film narrative
into four acts act 1 act 2a
act 2b
and act 3
and it contains 4 major story engines
that drive each one of the individual
acts
and 8 to 12
major signpost plot beats
it's not deciding what you will write
it's providing a form
and a template with which the writer
pours their story into so
a writer still makes their own unique
creative decisions
but they may want to think about what
page ranges those decisions fall in
and the kind of basic beats
that would inform the storytelling the
inciting incident should probably be
between eight eight to page eight to
twelve
but we also want something that i call
the strong movement forward the next
major beat to be in the page 18 to 20
range
sometimes that doesn't happen until 28
and then the true end of act 1
which should be around page 30
is in the beginner script not happening
until page 38 and that really makes the
reader
anxious and it slows down the pace of
the story and the structure
so it's not hitting the proper page
ranges
again this isn't deciding what you
should write but it's deciding
basically what page ranges the major
beats should be
how you should tell the story to some
extent okay kind of that outer frame of
the story with which you're pouring your
unique decisions into
but as far as mistakes there's a a major
signpost beat falling too early too late
or just not being there for example
there's a beat that i call the
assumption of power or declaration of
war beat and this should happen around
page 75 and you can see it in movies it
happens around minute 75
if that's not there if there's not that
moment where this character really feels
their true power
and acts in a way that makes them rise
to the occasion in kind of a a
declaration of war or an attack and a
declaration of intent
and something that taps their inner
strength if that's not happening in that
page range
i don't think the story is necessarily
moving as it should so a classic example
would be in the karate kid the show me
paint house moment show me paint the
fence show me sand the floor
and it's that moment at which daniel
larusso realizes he's been learning
karate all along even though mr miyagi
has been making him do all his chores
so he asks him to show him the the
positions that he's put his hands
as he's been doing these chores and it
turns out he's been learning karate this
whole time
so he really
daniel really realizes his true power
realizes he can do karate
and he's doing it already you want every
scene to advance the story
to explore the controlling theme or
reveal crucial character okay it has to
advance the story so definitely that
first one it has to do in some way
and then ideally it will also be on
theme that major theme that central
theme that this particular
story is exploring
and then third does it reveal some
crucial character you know something
that we haven't seen before
about this particular character i think
structure is very important in hitting
those page points is important
for no other reason because every reader
in hollywood has internalized that
structure
but i mean the real proof in the pudding
is that when you read proscripts by
produced writers by the top writers in
hollywood who are making the top money
they use this structure so there has to
be something about it that
is the reason why
the first act of a movie
is around 30 minutes i mean there's
something there there's some reason why
that works
blake came up with this idea of you know
sort of the 15 beats that make up any
story
um he put them on a beat sheet it's
become famous now for it's a great tool
for people who are developing a story
idea i think or trying to learn about
story structure
um so the one i will say the one thing
that i think people who are introduced
to the beat sheet maybe overlook and
then have to learn later so this is a
shortcut
is that some of the beats are
turning points and then some of the
beats are sections of the story so i'll
go over them
um but it's useful to note that because
i think that's one of the things that
confuses people when they're trying to
learn about the 15 beats
okay so the opening image is sort of the
first image of your screenplay or of
your movie it sets the tone
um kind of establishes when and where we
are in the world right um so the world
of your story the next beat that shows
up on the beat sheet is the theme stated
and um
blake wrote in save the cat i think that
theme stated shows up on page five of
your screenplay
um
it's you know the theme is usually
that sort of like guiding principle or
the the big idea of the story what it's
really about kind of behind the plot and
behind the characters right um and he
like to say that it was stated somewhere
in the story or you know on page five of
your screenplay it was stated outright
usually in a line of dialogue by one of
the characters
um the next beat on the um on the beat
sheet is the setup and that's one of
those beats to pay attention to because
the setup is actually a section of the
screen play right so it's not just one
page or one scene it's a whole section
um i think he notes that it the setup is
like page one to page
12 or so
um and so that's introducing us to the
main character and their ordinary world
or their normal world sort of where they
are in their life right now um before
the story gets started right and one of
the things he wrote about in save the
cat was that um you can kind of use the
idea of at home at work and at play to
introduce your protagonist so seeing
them in these different
sort of aspects of their their normal
world gives us a sense of who they are
the next beat on the beat sheet is the
catalyst and that is a beat that should
be
more of a turning point like one scene
or one moment in your screenplay
um the catalyst is also something that
other people refer to as the inciting
incident it's really the event that
kicks the story into motion um sometimes
you can think of it as the why now of
the story it's this event sort of you
know
throws your protagonist world into
disarray or forces them into action by
creating some sort of problem or
opportunity for them that they have to
take advantage of that they have to deal
with right and that's how it starts the
story into motion
uh the next beat is the debate section
and again it's it's a section of the
screenplay so this isn't just one scene
um i keep emphasizing that because i've
seen writers get confused and when
they're trying to outline their stories
they get to like the debate section and
they they put in one scene and then when
they go to write the screenplay they
don't have enough story to sort of fill
out the pages right
so the debate section is where is that
section in between the catalyst or the
inciting incident sort of kicking the
story into motion and your
protagonist deciding what to do about it
so there's that debate section in
between there
where we really um
try to sort of close all of the obvious
doors for your protagonist and funnel
them toward this main thing that they're
going to do over the course of the story
right
i also like to look at the debate
section as getting the audience on board
so you kind of tell us what's at stake
for the protagonist why they have to do
this thing because usually the thing
that they're going to do in act 2 is
this big audacious crazy scary dangerous
thing right so the debate section used
that to get the audience on board and
show us why do they need to do this
thing why is it so important what
happens if they don't do it help us
understand what the potential
consequences are so that we have that
tension of like wanting them to do it
but being a little bit worried about
them right before they go into act two
uh so the next beat is the break into
act two so at the end of the debate
section after you've gone through all of
that gotten the audience on board shown
us why the character has to do this
thing the break and act 2 is the turn in
your plot where you send the protagonist
into act 2 on to that main adventure
pursuing that story goal engaging in the
main conflict however you want to look
at it that's where that's what the break
into act 2 does
um the next section is the
b story
the next beat is the is the b story so
um blake like to say that you know sort
of after that main or that after that
major plot point of the break into act 2
um it was a good time to give your
protagonist and your audience a little
bit of a breather and introduce a
subplot
he talked about the b story being sort
of the
relationship or the subplot where your
character could discuss learning the
theme
so a lot of times it'll be
you know it might be a romance or it
might be a friendship or something but
it's giving your character an
opportunity to talk about what he's
learning talk about what he's going
through and what he's learning from it
the next uh beat on the beat sheet is
fun and games and again this is a
section of the story so uh the fun and
games is actually
on the beat sheet it's all of the first
half of act two right so it's it's
basically everything after the break
into two up until the midpoint which
we'll get to in a sec but so the fun and
games uh blake wrote that it was the is
where we see the promise of the premise
so um whatever the concept is of your
story the thing that's hooky and
intriguing about you know this story
that's where we see it sort of come to
fruition is in the fun and games so
um
i think his famous examples are liar
liar it's where we see jim carrey
getting used to not being able to tell a
lie
or in legally blonde it's where we see
elle getting acclimated to harvard law
and she's very much a fish out of water
so that's fun and game stuff you can
also think of it as trailer moments
right um those those very entertaining
and very like sort of on-concept
moments or scenes that you would
probably cut into a trailer to show
somebody what's so entertaining about
your movie
um
the next beat is the midpoint so that's
you know the middle of your story um
the midpoint is a is a more of a moment
or a scene
instead of a section so again just
making that distinction um but the
midpoint can be
a few scenes in a row right it's not
really a section of your screenplay but
it can be a sequence because usually
it's a big set piece or
like an action sequence or something
that is
a little bit bigger than other scenes
right
and really the function of the midpoint
is to
increase the opposition and or raise the
stakes of your story so basically what
it comes down to is the midpoint is
increasing the tension in your story to
sort of give it more momentum to get
through the second half right so
sometimes it turns the story in an
entirely new direction but doesn't
always have to um
in any case what it does is it it
increases sort of that that tension
feeling so that it's sort of like you
know
uh winding up a toy and letting it go so
it gives us that extra momentum and
energy to get through the second half of
the story
then after the midpoint uh the next beat
on the beat sheet is the bad guys close
in
so blake like to say that this is sort
of where um things really start going
wrong for your protagonist right so
uh you can have both external and
internal bad guys so it can be plot
stuff is going wrong the literal bad
guys can be closing in you know getting
closer gaining on your protagonist but
it can also be
emotional stuff they're really
struggling with what they're doing they
feel like they can't succeed and maybe
they're having a crisis of faith or of
confidence
um
and then you can also have conflict
within the protagonist team so that's
also causing things to fall apart right
and basically the bad guys close in
section is leading us sort of downhill
towards the next couple of beats which
are the um all is lost and dark night of
the soul beats and these are separate
beats on the beat sheet but i sort of
like to talk about them together because
they really are complementary and they
work together to kind of create that
low point at the end of act two
um so i sort of like to think of them as
one is um more external or plot focused
and one is more internal or character
focused uh the all is lost is um usually
sort of what i think of as the plot
focused one right where it's it looks
like the character the protagonist is
not going to succeed it you might think
of it as he's you know as far away from
his goal as he'll ever be or he feels
like he's failing he feels like there's
no hope he doesn't know how he's going
to keep going on and try to get that
goal
um and then the dark knight of the soul
is sort of the emotional reaction to
that
um
other things that can happen at the all
is lost can be like the death of a
mentor
i think this is where
uh blake wrote that there's like that
whiff of death right so it can be the
loss or death of a mentor or of a friend
or of a support system
um it can be a major setback like um
you know being exposed
to the bad guys so now they know who who
they're up against or it can be like
losing an advantage you know but you
want it to be pretty big because we're
talking about kind of the big turning
points of the story
um and then the dark night of the soul
is the emotional reaction to that right
so it's now that this big setback has
happened or it looks like i'm not going
to be able to achieve my goal
the protagonist sort of sitting in that
for a moment and wondering what do i do
from here
and a lot of times that's where they
have kind of a glimmer of
i finally understand the lesson of the
theme i finally understand what i should
be learning from this experience
um
they they're not always ready to embrace
that lesson at that point yet right but
they're starting to understand like oh
this is what all of this has been trying
to teach me
um
and then after that the next beat is the
break into act three
um so that's the major turning point
where we go from act two to act three
and
um
basically it's the beginning of the
resolution section of the story right so
that turn you usually want it to feel
like it's sort of pushing us
in a new direction that is toward
however the story is going to resolve
right so your character your protagonist
might have a new plan so after that dark
night of the soul moment they might have
a moment of inspiration where they're
like oh okay now i know what i what i
need to do right now i know how to
defeat this bad guy and so the break
into three is where they begin that that
final push to resolve
that story right that main conflict or
um
you know however you want to think about
that that story so the next beat on the
beat sheet after the break into act 3 is
the finale and this is the section that
most people forget is a section of the
story instead of um one scene right so
your finale or the way blake wrote about
the finale um is that the finale was all
of act three so it's what you would call
the resolution right or he called it the
finale um
so this is where we see that new plan
that your protagonist has play out or we
see them execute that that final push
toward trying to resolve the main
conflict um so
finale all of act three
um
i think that is that is that beat 14 and
then there's 15 is the final image okay
so the last beat on the beat sheet is
the final image so that's after the
finale has played out we've seen how the
main conflict has resolved we've seen if
the protagonist has
you know achieved his goal if they've
succeeded or failed how the out you know
how the story um
ends basically like what is the final
outcome and then we have the very last
beat which is the final image which sort
of is that
you know you might think of it as like
um almost the aftermath of the of the
finale it's now that the story is over
give us one kind of final scene or image
or moment to kind of send the audience
out
feeling how you want them to feel um
knowing maybe what the character is
going to do next or
um
you know if you need to
sort of recalibrate the the emotion at
the end of your story maybe the maybe
the um the end of the finale was a big
action sequence and you want to leave us
feeling like knowing that your
protagonist was okay and he won and he's
safe and he's you know rested and not
injured anymore or something like that
the final image can can do that um blake
also like to write that it was uh the
final image is like a bookend for the
opening image right so
you know i think um
some people
look at it as you want the
the change or the contrast between the
opening image and the final image to
be big enough to sort of uh show that
there was a transformation in that in
that story right so we went from point a
to point z and there's a big enough
contrast there that we can see this
story you know covered some ground and
had some consequence to it if that makes
sense
the first speeches i ever wrote for were
for tedx orange coast i wrote eight of
them and i was like i don't know what
i'm doing
you know uh i know how to tell a story
but i didn't really know how do you get
the person's life from point a to point
b
to the end right and
so i would get halfway through the
script and
by the way i had to turn around a lot of
the scripts in two to three weeks
eight of them
wow so i didn't have much time and i was
working seven days a week and like i
better figure this out oh my goodness
right
and um so the rules were
i was anti-rule
really and
then
one day i was working on a on a
speech for this ted talk one of them and
i wanted to do this woman justice i just
adored her her name's amy purdy and she
and i were collaborating together
and i just thought i've got to do this
justice
what how do i tell a story you know we
were
in there we were doing stuff but i uh
it just wasn't hitting the mark and so i
said okay google let's look at my magic
eight ball let me just shake it and see
what comes back and i just typed in
story arc
and
all of a sudden
i clicked on images
and i saw something called the hero's
journey
and i was like you know what i feel like
i've heard about that before what is
this crazy thing called the heroes
journey and i looked at the visual it's
a beautiful visual somebody taking their
time to really show me all the steps and
i was like wait this is how i this is
how this works i can do this this is
exactly what i need amy had eight
minutes ted talks are often 18 minutes
but she only had eight minutes that's
what they gave her
and some of my other speakers had 12
minutes and you know which four minutes
is a huge difference
let me tell you eight is tight
and so i was like i can do this i can
cross a threshold with her story
this is wonderful
and we did it and her talk went viral
and so this was back in 2011
and
it was affirmation for me and i was like
i don't know these hollywood people this
way but i love them
and so
then i started following that for
certain people i started using the
hero's journey and
because there are
there are emotional beats in there
and i noticed that my speeches were
following those beats
i would just look over i'd be like is
this going the way it is i would find it
i would just mirror them and they could
almost cross map
and
what was beautiful about that is that
the the people i tend to work with the
speakers i tend to work with and
especially now now that i've been doing
this a long time
i'm really i really want
beauty out in the world and i want
my speakers to disseminate that
that beauty which they already have in
them
right and the hero's journey really does
that because the audience doesn't hear
the speaker
they hear what the speaker has been
through but they only think about
themselves and what they've been through
in relation to what that speaker has
been through
so you know speakers will be like i
don't know if i could say that and i'm
like it's not about you the audience is
gonna
say oh my god i went through that too
you know or my mother went through that
or someone i knew or you know and they
they start to
they hear your story but in relationship
to themselves and so that that hero's
journey has been incredibly important
in in
in the storytelling process
the first act has to deliver
the dramatic question
you know ideally there is a protagonist
who has a very clear objective
ideally there are stakes so there are
consequences if that protagonist doesn't
succeed
and the higher those stakes the more
dramatic the story
ideally there is a scene and there's a
whole book
save the cat that is kind of based on
that
ideally you have given the audience a
reason to
side with that protagonist which a lot
of movies and scripts leave out
completely which is amazing to me
because it's one of the main ingredients
why would i as an audience care if that
character sees his father before he dies
you know there must be something that
shows me a humanity inside of that
character it can be a bad bad mafia
serial killer whatever guy
but something that i can relate to where
we share
our humanity in that moment so that he
becomes the vehicle for me to discover
things
about myself in the end i think that's
the secret that every audience it's a
very
that's a very selfish process i think
every audience really comes to the
theater to learn something about
themselves and not about oklahoma or
space or whatever but about their
emotions in that moment but that only
works if you can create a connection
between the protagonist and the audience
earlier
so that would probably be the formula
looking for is there a connection
is there a clear
want which leads to the dramatic
question which is will this protagonist
successfully save the love of his life
whatever whatever and then you go into
the second act where there are
where you have to look at the conflicts
is there enough
is is what he the steps he is doing are
they escalating in a way that at the
same time is believable
but also doesn't need too much patience
because in real life he would probably
first phone his grandmother and then he
would go
we don't want to sit through all that we
want the condensed version we want the
fake version but we want it to feel
emotionally real which is a hard thing
to achieve but it's something that you
can very clearly track
throughout a second act i think and the
first half of the second act normally
traditionally is called like the fun and
games
part which is
where most the sea of the scenes that
you see in a trailer are in the first
half of the second act where
the promise of the movie the reason why
people came
is to see those scenes
you know it's like oh there's a
a man that talks to his snake mel gibson
with this beaver and jody foster's movie
you know that would be the first
half of the second act where we kind of
have a little bit of time the clock
isn't ticking quite as fast yet
and then most of the time the mid
point halfway through the story is a
more fundamental
twist to the whole story
it turns out the beaver
is real or has whatever whatever you
know can actually talk
something that changes
our whole look on the story and the
direction of the story which i think is
super important because otherwise a
second act gets very long like if it's
only a one directional thing which
exists of course and is exists
successfully but it's very hard to
execute to keep the audience's attention
without something that in the middle
kind of breaks the movie
up and gives it a whole different
direction and a lot of time like in a
spy movie it would be our protagonist
finds out that the agency he's working
for is actually the the bad guys
so suddenly it's or in
mad max it's when they've been driving
into that one direction and now they've
achieved whatever they need to achieve
and now they're literally turning around
coming back that would be kind of the
midpoint
then the stakes have to be raised in the
second half
of the second act and lead to the major
confrontation
then if you go by the heroes journey
which i believe in a lot joseph campbell
and all that kind of stuff
there is the major confrontation it
looks like the hero is going to die he
metaphorically dies sheds his old ego
learned something about himself that he
didn't know before there's most of the
time painful
and that enables him because he doesn't
break in that moment he almost breaks
you get him to the breaking point and
you can see that in almost every movie
that that is being done because we need
to really break a character to see what
he's made of right if you never
challenge a character you don't know
what he really has inside of
so you almost break him and in that
process of staring death in the face
metaphorically or obviously in a
romantic comedy it would be
the girl is
dating another guy you know it doesn't
have to be death literally but it's the
death of that
so now our protagonist learns something
about himself that was in his blind spot
that he didn't know before which now
enables him
to be to use that as a tool to change
that's why character arcs and
development are so important become a
different person and that enables him to
achieve the goal that he hadn't been
able to achieve before nowhere in the
third act where most of the time he has
to defend where he's
where he is challenged by the
antagonistic force that he's been
battling throughout the second act one
last time and that's where the big
dragon or sauron or whatever you know
rears his head for the first time
attacks him and he has to prove that the
change that he just went through is a
permanent one that can be challenged and
he
will still survive with his old ego
end of story so that would be at least
the
that is the mythology the
thousands of years old
you know paradigm that stories are
building you can go away from that
paradigm as much as you want but i think
it helps to
know that that is what audiences
intuitively are expecting and someone
who does that really great is tarantino
like i don't think there's anyone who
knows this story structure better and
messes with it and messes with your
expectation which is great but it's
different from not knowing it and just
writing something into the blue and then
wondering why people don't identify with
the characters or aren't hooked to a
certain development or something like
that
so that would be my
my formula structure that i kind of if
i'm if i'm reading it and i'm engrossed
then it doesn't matter you know if it's
a three-act structure or whatever but if
i feel like my attention kind of drifts
and i don't really care most of the time
the answer is in
that structure that somehow doesn't
deliver what it needs to deliver
one of the single most important aspects
of screenwriting any long-form narrative
in novel writing to it just
screenwriting in particular
is change
things thus everything in the story must
keep changing as it flows it got it it
has to be different five ten minutes
from now than than what the
circumstances were
previously 10 minutes ago it has to keep
changing and i
i came to believe there had to be a
pattern of change
and what i discovered was this
this gets a little numeric you know
stick with me for this uh uh because
it's it's important and i think
enormously useful
uh
three acts okay in a screenplay you've
got three acts
first act
in act one
i noticed
there are six
sequences
following one another
that i called i came to call hero goal
sequences
here's the definition for a hero goal
sequence
a hero goal sequence
is any two to seven page
section of your
screenplay in which and through which
your hero or heroine pursues
one
short-term goal physical short-term goal
only one
as one step
toward
achieving the overall story goal
right just just that little piece of it
and at the end of that
seven or so nothing is exact you know
but seven or so pages
something happened or some discovery is
made by this hero
that i call fresh news
in other words they turn up something
that was unknown by them and by us by
the audience about what they are doing
that puts an end to that current single
goal
and offers up a new
short term
physical single goal to be pursued in
the next
step
and that there are six of these hero
goal sequences
six little individual pursuits of
individual specific goals
in the entirety of act one
and what we call
there's many names
for uh this plot point one there's the
the the first major turning point uh
that kind of thing i call it stunning
surprise one when stunning surprise one
happens which ends act one officially
and dramatically ends act one and kicks
the hero forward tumbling head over heel
into act two
i call it stunning surprise one because
that should be i believe the emotional
impact on both the hero and the audience
it needs to be emotional and it needs to
be impactful not abstract
that always happens in hebrew goal
sequence six
always
and it continues
in the first half
of the second act
there are six more hero goal sequences
and hero goal sequence number 12
always contains the midpoint sequence
that's a separate discussion the
midpoint is a fascinating part of movies
that work and it's it's
it's rich and layered with things that
go on relative to character growth and
relative to the plot being you know
bumped up to the next level and all
but
it always happens in number 12.
in the second half of act two
there are six more wonder of wonders
there are six more hero goal sequences
and hero goal sequence 18
always contains
stunning surprise too
not 17
not 19
18
in every movie that works for audiences
in ev in other words every hit movie
that you can analyze because it's doing
something right
this is the pattern
and then in act 3
it's the only act where it can vary
where the numbers can vary and in act 3
you have between two and five hero gold
sequences
i don't recommend five five it's
good movies have been made with five
like uh
as good as it gets which has to be you
know one of my favorite romantic
comedies kind of it has five hero goal
sequences in in in rather extended act
three
but the audience is getting antsy and
it's time to get out by then i i the
standard the average of movies that work
is 21
21 hero goal sequences
18 for acts one and two
and then another three
in act three
this is a way i know it sounds kind of
weird and mathematical at this point but
this is a way of quantifying
change
it tells you in advance
this must happen in these few pages
there it also goes beyond that i mean
people were asking you well and what
specifically happens in each one of
these can you nail that down in a
general way yeah i do that in the book
you know i say well these things usually
happen in hero goal sequence number four
you know that kind of stuff
but that's up for grabs enough for
people to play with
but structurally the bones are these 20
to 23 hero goal sequences laid out in
this exact way
and they don't change
it's a three-step process called
sequence proposition plot
that was invented by william thompson
price the first step sequence is reverse
cause and effect it's the sequence of
cause and effect
that constitute
the spine of the story
the forward progression of the story
so that
using reverse cause and effect you have
to have the
mechanics of the story
sketched out first you can't do plot
construction until you have a story
reasonably well figured out with reverse
cause and effect you start at the ending
and work backwards so that you are
you're looking at the ending and you're
chaining back from each effect to its
cause
so you look at the ending and say okay
well what would be the immediate cause
of that ending
and you find the cause of that and then
you say okay what would be the immediate
cause of that and the cause of that and
so on
and
so that
say it's a
it's a um
say it's a story about a
uh someone who's being muscled by a
mafia don
no someone who's being muscled by a
corrupt cop
and
the corrupt cop puts him in a
good strong dilemma
and there's no way out and it gets worse
and worse and worse
and
this character finally figures a way out
and that he
makes a deal with a mafia don
to set up this corrupt cop because the
mafia don wants to take out this corrupt
cop
so the character sets a trap
so that
the crooked cop shows up to like rob him
at the at the key point and the mafiadon
swoops in and takes him out
so
the ending would be
that the guy is free from the trap he
was caught in before you'd say well what
would cause him to be free it's that the
mafia don
snatches the crooked cop and disappears
him
the cause of that
would be that
the crooked cop swoops in to steal the
loot the cause of that is that he
sets up
the heist the fake heist to lure the
crooked cop in the cause of that is that
he makes the deal with the mafia dawn
so when you play that and that's all
right
dense part of the ending but you could
see the cause and effect there where
he makes the deal with the corrupt mafia
dom which causes him to be able to set
up the crooked heist
which causes
him to have the the loot which causes
the crooked cop to swoop in and take it
which causes the mafiodon to be able to
grab the cop and disappear which caused
them to
walk out of the trap that he was in
so it's
it's a way of
of
not only stitching together
the the story components by cause and
effect but
actually um
creating that cause and effect where it
may not exist in other words
if you have your story roughed out and
you start doing reverse cause and effect
and you start chaining backwards through
from each effect back to its cause you
may get to a point where
there isn't a cause in what you've
figured out so far
and that may be a hole in your plot in
the logic of the plot and you say well
what would cause that to happen
and you may come up with a bunch of
different possibilities find the one
that works and
so then you have the next cause and then
what's the cause of that so
not only are you
knitting it together as you build
backwards you're taking what you've
already got a story that's
that you've sketched out but you're now
it's like
it's like the um
when when you've
designed a project and you know exactly
what you want it to do
then you bring in the engineer and say
okay
make all the nuts and bolts of this
actually work here's exactly what we
want but you got to do the engineering
so we know how heavy the steel has to be
how much concrete to pour and they'll
give you hard numbers of like you need
this much concrete and this much steel
so there's one thing of what you want to
achieve there's another of
the engineer comes in and makes it all
tells you what to do to make it all work
it's that kind of thing
that as you
take the story you've roughed out and
stitch it together engineer it that you
actually
create the cause and effect as you build
and
the trick to that tool is that you are
asking at each point only
what is the cause of that effect
rather than what happens before it
because any number of things can happen
before it but only one thing actually
caused it so that's a way to help
separate the necessary from the
unnecessary you're creating a chain as
you work backwards
and when you
create the chain for the overall story
the chain of events
and you've rigorously
included only that which is necessary to
the forward action of the story and
you've rigorously excluded
that which is unnecessary to the forward
progression of events that constitute
the spine of your story
then
you've assembled it backwards out of
your what the material you have and when
you find holes in your plot you invent
to fill them in
so you're not only
structuring it but you're also
developing it you're creating when
needed
then when you read it from the bottom up
a causes b which causes c which causes d
and so on
that's the spine of your story
whereas before you had a lot of
clever elements to a story and it looked
like it worked but you hadn't
done the engineering on it to make sure
it really
worked
and
being able to stand back and look at
your story
like it starts here and it moves all
through here
it also enables you to get a good
objective look at what you've created so
far the second step
comes from
price's proposition that we were talking
about before using logic to pull all the
story elements together into a coherent
hole
like we were talking about how
pulp fiction has three different stories
in it
but tarantino did an excellent job of
pulling those all together into a
coherent hole
it's not a mess of different stuff it's
one thing that happens to be done in an
unusual way but it's still
perfectly crafted from a dramatic point
of view it's it's extremely effective
dramatically
and great storytelling has got both
so
once you've got this tight chain of
events
then you
set up a set up a conflict set up a
potential conflict early on in the story
touch off a fight to the finish later in
the story
and what price said is instead of doing
a and b therefore c
he said central to our job as a
dramatist is to have the audience up on
the edge of their seat at the point when
the fight to the finish has only just
started and they don't know how it's
going to turn out
so at the point when the fight to the
finish has only just started
the audience comes up on the edge of
their seat like how's this going to turn
out because we've got a powerful
proactive protagonist and we've got a
powerful proactive antagonist and we
genuinely don't genuinely don't know
who's going to win how it's going to
turn out
and
so you set it up you touch it off you
get the audience on the edge of their
seat and you've either got the audience
or you don't
in terms of dramatic power on a scale of
1 to 10
how much are they on the edge of their
seat
if it's
really powerful then you're going wow
yes this i set it up i touched it off
and i really got the audience
if you set it up you touch it off and
you can see
it's still kind of weak or it's actually
quite weak
that's the power that's what the
proposition is for so you can propose it
take an objective look at it and then
evaluate it and then revise as needed
if it's only like a seven out of ten
and you're like no it needs to be i need
a nine or a ten in terms of a scale of
one to ten for how powerfully i have the
audience on the edge of their seat at
this point when the
when what the whole story is built up to
is unresolved
then you amplify different aspects of it
to get the audience that much more on
the edge of rc
so you're
you're creating a tight sequence of
cause and effect then looking at the
core conflict in the story because it's
really just two boxers in a ring
fighting it out it's two dogs fighting
over a bone only one of them is going to
walk away in the end
in fact the oldest greek drama was only
two characters on stage the introduction
of the third character by sophocles was
considered a major innovation in drama
so the ability to see the core of your
plot as two
main
fighters in a fight to the finish and
only one of them is going to walk away
helps you get right at the core of what
makes your story work dramatically the
last step is the answering of the riddle
the completion of the action what how
the fight to the finish
shakes out in the back and forth between
protag and his antagonist and who wins
or loses in the end
so
reverse cause and effect
set up the fight touch it off get the
audience on the edge of their seat
and wrap it up
so that's sequence proposition plot
some writing teachers say the three act
structure is dead
it's um it's it's remedial
um
it's
it it's it's not going to um it's it's
going to
kill
uh any creativity
and the problem with that is that um
they don't understand what the three-act
structure is because the three-act
structure is um
has nothing to do with plotting in my
opinion and unfortunately the a lot of
story structure is taught
by story analysts who are sort of
brilliant left-brained
brainers and are really adept at
deconstructing
a masterpiece
and and sort of the implication is that
now that we've deconstructed this you
should go off and write your masterpiece
and while there's tremendous amount of
value
in in in studying film theory or or or
uh or
you know
film theory because it's that that's
that's you know deconstructing
casablanca or citizen kane
is
is going to help you understand
uh
uh how
a story was built to some degree but
it's not going to teach you process
it's not going to teach you how to
organize
your ideas when you look at a movie like
casablanca and uh you think about the
epstein brothers writing
you know we're structuring this this
movie
they um
i'm interested in in the process i'm
interested in
how did somebody come to write this in
other words you can you can sort of like
just because you deconstruct something
it's like vivisection you can't you
can't take something
dead and look at all of its existing
parts
and then
and then reanimate it it's not going to
come back to life and so just because
you can break down this thing into its
its sort of separate parts
doesn't mean you're going to uncover the
mystery of what the thing actually is in
other words story structure is really
the dna of your protagonist's
transformation that makes sense story
shows the dna of a protagonist
transformation
it's not
you know in the midpoint there should be
a um a reversal like i don't even know
what that means you hear it all the time
with with uh uh
these story analysts that should be
reversible what the hell
does um you know does does
it's a wonderful life have a a reversal
that's where mr potter offers jimmy
stewart a job and jimmy stewart says no
i don't know i i don't i think of i
think of story structure as
uh not a conceptual model something you
can figure out but it's it's more of a
experiential model in other words your
protagonist goes through a series of
experiences that lead to a
transformation and
i think of story structure as an
immutable
paradigm
for a spiritual transformation okay it's
immutable it never changes
but that doesn't make it that doesn't
um
that doesn't limit your creativity that
actually
paradoxically
opens your creativity in other words
when when you really understand what
story structure is it moves you beyond
your limited imagination of what your
story is i always tell my writers your
idea of your story is not the whole
story it's not that it's incorrect it's
that it's incomplete and so if you were
to distill story structure to three
words
it would be
desire
surrender
transformation
so show me any story
there's you're going to have a character
that wants something desire you're going
to have a character that lets go of the
meaning they made out of their goal
surrender you're going to have a
character that experiences
transformation in other words a shift in
perception a reframing of their
relationship to their goal
show me a story
that doesn't have that and i'll show you
a story that doesn't work
you know or is
really experimental
everything was in a four-act structure
on television because it had to allow
for advertising
every uh 13 minutes or so so you would
divide your 60 minutes
into
roughly four acts roughly four 15-minute
segments they weren't really exactly 15
minutes but something like that
so that there could be a commercial
break
at the end of each one
and then there was a teaser
generally this traditional traditional
structure which i'll tell you was the
show's title with even a theme song
then sometimes
there was
a small commercial even right away
and then there's the teaser
anywhere from 30 seconds to five minutes
which
literally teases the action or sometimes
in a procedural would give you the crime
or the case to be solved
then there'd be a commercial
then you'd go into act one
which would go to
roughly
20 minutes 18 20 pages
then there'd be a commercial act 2 would
go to roughly 30 ish pages
this is traditional
act break
act three
which is the
uh worst case the climactic
encounter
uh would go to roughly page 45-ish
and then act four
would go
to the end and would be slightly shorter
would probably be 57 58 or 55 minutes
and then there'd be another act break uh
and and another uh
commercial then it got longer
and in uh 2006
abc decided that they wanted to go to
six acts in order to stick stick in more
commercials
and so you ended up with a very long act
one
so the people wouldn't lose you and then
they break act six into uh
act four into
four and five and then there would be a
tag
after the final
act which sometimes led into the next
week
and they would get more commercials in
and this just got worse and worse and
worse and worse
where there were
some
shows on traditional networks
that had almost more commercial material
than dramatic material in terms of
structure after you get
to your final act
in some shows uh not all of them
there's a form where
there's an act break or a break of some
sort and then there's more dramatic
material
and that extra dramatic material is
usually quite short
it might be one scene or two scenes
maybe three scenes but not really much
longer
and either it does something
as a commentary on what that episode was
about and twists it
or
it just simply
starts introducing what's going to be on
the next episode
uh every show is different you don't
find this sort of thing very much on on
streaming and so this we're really when
we talk about act breaks and the four or
five or six acts or the number of acts
plus the teaser and a tag we're really
we're really dealing with traditional
legacy television i found that even
after
uh the traditional
forex structure was abandoned by
networks
that as i talked to people who are
writing for
netflix or hbo or any other form at all
amazon
when i talked to seasoned writers
they were all still using it and just
dropping out the act break
and the reason they were using it is
that it works
it works as a storytelling mechanism
even if it does not need to be something
that accommodates advertising
and that was very interesting that given
the option to not use it
plenty of people figured out
gee i need a form anyway
and you don't just start on page one and
go to page 60 or whatever
you know in a row without having any
idea
uh where the where the changes are where
the emphasis are where the energy
goes this way or that way
what about cliffhangers and it was
discovered by a number of of seasoned
writers that you know what
i can go back to the tools that i always
used without ever having calling it a
break or having an ad
and what it has to do with the rhythm of
experience
that uh there is a something but i think
there may be something biological
in the
roughly 15-minute
span
if you go to a movie
uh a movie in a theater
of which there aren't very many anymore
but if you were to go in a movie in a
successful movie in a theater
and you observe you'd know you might
notice that roughly every 13 or 15
minutes a little around
the audience squirms
and i've observed this several times and
i think it is actually biological i
think people are looking for a change of
pace they're looking for a
cliffhanger they're looking for
something that turns the action
in another direction in what uh
some people have called a plot point
though you don't need to use that
terminology and
uh
i think there is something to rid the
rhythm of writing
uh
in fact if you look at the traditional
three-act structure this the old sid
feels 3x structure uh which wasn't
invented by sid fields it predates him
by a long time but anyway
that structure said
that
act
act one was one quarter of the time
act two is two quarters of the time half
and act three is one quarter of the time
and that's how the three acts work
they're not three even acts the second
act is double
but if you draw a median line down the
middle of that second act
which is often where the uh
mid
story character comes in and chan where
there's a big change you're back you've
got four acts
and so you're still back to the same
thing
now it plays out differently in a
hundred minutes than it would in 60
minutes but not that differently
um
[Music]
and so people experiment with
what netflix will tell you and what hbo
will tell you
is don't talk to me about act breaks
write what the story needs
write it whatever length the story needs
to be
and we'll deal with it
and i think that's wonderful as a very
generous way of approaching writers
the writer still has to go home
and structure the story
so what the story needs to be still
needs turns
still needs anticipation
still needs what used to be called plot
points
still needs a motor
that
drives to certain kinds of flips
and uh and still needs some sort of
resolution so you find yourself back
with some of the
most traditional uh
lessons in how to write uh as you write
for even the most advanced television
when you're staffed right you're writing
to whatever the network or the streaming
service does
there's there's a variety of different
structures that that brings about for
instance most of the abc dramas that i
know of i will not say all about any of
them are written in six act structure
so what 6x structure means is that
you're you're basically everything's
kind of a little symmetrical right
you've got this many pages here this
many pages in each act
building to those act out through those
commercial breaks
and because it's so act out driven
it really changes the pacing of the show
if you wat most abc shows will feel like
they move very quickly and it's because
of that sort of symmetrical nature of
the axe
shows on cbs are often teaser four
is the structure it's also often called
five act structure it sort of just
depends on who's referring to it
but what it does is allow you to write a
longer teaser that can sometimes be more
luxurious and get more of your story set
up
and then you you use the following forex
to you know complete your storytelling
shows that i i will say i think have
done that are like the good wife right
would sometimes have those really long
opening setups before the title card so
that's your long luxurious teaser and
then the rest of the show is the
five-act structure
um
so those that's sort of the main stuff
six act teaser four
or five act five act tends to um
have a shorter teaser
that then the
basically starts
act one so it's like short teaser title
card rest of act one
as opposed to being a separate entity
like teaser four is
um so those are the varying sort of
different things and you can
you know again if you can get a hold of
scripts for different shows you can
research how they did it
in streaming shows when you read our
scripts there there won't be any act
designations because there are typically
no commercial breaks although
now that you know netflix is going to
have an ad tier i don't
know if that's going to change or
they're going to ask us to tell them
where the commercial breaks are like we
do in broadcast
tbd
but
um again to something i spoke about
earlier and that i think is really
important breaking the story as if those
act breaks exist
will help with your storytelling and
help with the emotional ebb and flow of
the episode so that it doesn't feel like
you're waiting till the end of the show
to do all the really important things
because i think what happens is people
are like well we can have all these nice
long conversations or we can have this
great big huge set piece but then you're
not really
getting a lot of variation in the
episode it's just sort of like talk talk
talk talk talk everything happens or
it's like talking talking huge set piece
talking talking talking talking talking
boom ending
and that's like a it's not really a
great pleasurable experience when you
watch tv you want to sort of like be
drawn in and then like okay i can rest a
little bit
um so that that act break structure
even if you take act breaks out of your
script is a really good way to do it in
most shows you will have your a story is
the
main story of the episode it is the
driving story usually of your main
characters
uh not always true but often true
and so say for instance and i'll use
swat as an example because we very
clearly wrote a b and c stories
so your a story is the crime of the week
right what who are the bad guys we're
challenging what have they done what are
we trying to stop them from doing
and you will develop that whole story
and who in our cast is that story really
affecting right now eight out of ten
episodes that's going to be hondo
but sometimes it's a personal case from
the past for one of our other characters
or if someone's friend was injured in
the crime and so they're the ones who
are emotionally affected by what we're
doing
so that's your a story your b story and
your c story
are
the supporting stories in the episode
and they are usually more character
focused
so it's a chance for your second tier
characters to sort of get moments right
so say
again in an episode of swat a b story
might be
um
street and chris have like
admitted that they like each other but
they're still like oh can we date no we
can't date what are we going to do about
this mess so that romantic intrigue is
your b story
sometimes it also will cross into your a
story right because it's like
they're on a call together and they've
just had this fight about the fact that
they can't date each other but then like
something dangerous happens and then
it's so clear that much they love each
other right so it's like you're building
that stuff into the a story but you're
breaking their arc on its own
and then a c story is usually a runner
right it's like a three four beat story
that sometimes adds some humor to the
episode
sometimes it's to tie off a loose end
that we've left floating from a prior
episode of like
did that couple break up we don't know
and so we'll do like three beats where
we finally reveal like did the couple
break up oh no no they're still together
look at that surprise like whatever it
is
um sometimes it's a way to give an actor
who has maybe not been as focused on in
the show a chance to shine so you're
giving them three or four scenes that
are really about them and their
character
and letting them sort of like you know
hey i'm here pay attention to me
so
that's really what those things break
down to it's your main story your
secondary story and then c story is
usually a runner
um you will sometimes like in a finale
episode your b and c stories will feel
about equal because you know finales are
all about wrapping up the emotional arcs
of the entire season so sometimes it's
like you've got three relationship
stories going and you have to get
somewhere with all of them
so
you'll you know you suss that out in the
moment but that's in general how that
works
because short films can do anything or
say anything and they should be
unexpected and you can do act
you know you're ending at the beginning
and you're beginning at the end there is
no structure so but i do think
simplicity helps a lot i don't think you
should have a hundred different
characters with a hundred different
plots going on and a b lines it's not
like screenwriting that's when people
take do a short film screenwriting i'm
always kind of like what could you be
talking about because there aren't the
same kind of rules as there are for
features it really depends on what story
you want to tell and then i just think
it's a lot about simplification
and really bringing it down to a simple
idea and one thing i love about short
films because i'm known for short films
right people will always say to me oh i
saw this really great short film and
then they'll tell me the short film that
they saw so i haven't visually seen it
but i've heard someone tell me to and
i'll be like that sounds like a great
short film and i kind of feel like i've
seen it because they were able to tell
me the whole plot of what it was
so you know
your short story your short film should
work in that way that people can tell
you what it is but a lot of them are
like just visual one of my favorite
kinds of short films are dialogue free
short films where there's absolutely no
dialogue but it is all told you know
it's not like an old-fashioned running
pushing piano up the hill and having a
fall down laurel and hardy kind of thing
but just you can tell a story
with visuals
the actual old-fashioned visual
filmmaking way um and it's great
and so many and those i'll also say the
short films with no dialogue translate
very well translate very well for
different countries people love films
with no dialogue because it's universal
it's going to be a universal story of
something that is told through cinema
it's a very cinematic way of telling a
story but anyway so yeah nothing you
know you can do anything you want to do
and i could try to talk you out of like
don't do like traditional structure but
you can do traditional structure if
that's what your story needs and is to
be told um
endings are really important in short
films beginnings are really important to
short films and middles are very
important in short films i do think
every scene in your short film should
also you've got to look at it and say
beginning and ending you know are we
lingering too long can we get out and do
that before you shoot it because you
know again
every moment counts and if you're going
to have a longer shoot if you have a
bunch of stuff in it that later you're
going to cut out in editing
evaluate every scene look at the does it
start as late as it can does it end as
early as it possibly can and then do you
really need it
what is the scene actually about and
have we already done that i hate short
films where it just takes forever to get
to the storyline or they
they have a big opening credit sequence
of somebody driving in a car with
beautiful scenery going on and the
credits say you know costumes buy and dp
buy and it's like no for feature films
contractually you have to do that they
have to have full screen credits for
short film there's nothing like that we
have no opening credit sequence people
don't want to sit through that we don't
want to see that start right away with
what your story is
and you know you don't everything should
be what needs to be nothing superfluous
nothing that is just there because it
may entertains you um you know you can
have a super chatty film too
but just make sure everything that's in
there and chatty needs to be in there
so so i say probably the biggest thing
about the structure is just
make sure it starts good make sure it
ends good make sure everything in there
needs to be in there has to be in there
and as tight as possible
and that you're happy with it